we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine to david p and here is a
voicemail that we received yo david i'm
just calling was listening to your show
the other day and learned something very
interesting so i was a kind of behind on
your show and i was looking to catch up
so i was listening to your podcast on
one and a half times speed trying cover
more ground and what I found was you
speak with such deliberation that even a
one and a half times speed it's a very
believable speed for someone to speak at
normally I should check that out it's an
interesting but um I think even more
interesting the man was that Donald
Trump at one and a half times speed
sounds like an auction year because of
how frequently he repeats himself and
how quickly he already talked yeah I can
imagine how that we met up for good
laugh so uh Mary David love the show
diggity yo Jay Tomlinson host the best
of the left podcast told me he listens
to my show and all shows at one and a
half speed just because he has so much
stuff to listen to that it just covers
more ground he covers more ground that
way that is very funny we've got a great
bonus show for you today but no time to
tell you what's on it trust me trust me
this I can assure you as Donald Trump
would say it's a good one